let's see if we can find the limit as h
approaches 0 of 5 log of 2 plus h minus
5 log of 2 all of that over h
and i'll give you a little bit of a hint
because i know you're about to pause the
video and try to work through it think
of your derivative properties especially
the derivative of logarithmic functions
especially logarithmic functions in this
case with base 10. if someone just
writes log without the base you can just
assume that that is a 10 right over
there so pause the video and see if you
can work through it
all right so the key here is to remember
that if i have
if i have f of x let me do it over here
i'll do it over here f of x
and i want to find
f prime of
let's say f prime of
some number let's say a this is going to
be equal to
the limit
as x or sorry as h approaches 0 is one
way of thinking about it as h approaches
0 of f of a plus h
minus f of a
all of that over h
so this looks pretty close to that limit
definition except we have these fives
here but lucky for us we can factor out
those fives and we could factor them out
we could factor them out out front here
but if you just have a scalar times the
expression we know from our limit
properties we can actually take those
out of the limit themselves so let's do
that let's take both of these fives and
factor them out and so this whole thing
is going to simplify to 5
times the limit
as h approaches 0 of log of 2 plus h
minus
minus log
of 2
all of that
over h
now you might recognize what we have in
yellow here let's think about it what
this is if we had f of x
is equal to
log
of x
and we wanted to know what f prime
of well actually let's say f prime of 2
is
well this would be the limit
as h approaches 0
of log of 2 plus h
2 plus h
minus log of 2 minus log of 2
all of that over h
so this is really just a what we see
here this by definition
this right over here is
is f prime of 2. if f x is log of x this
is f prime of 2
f prime of 2.
so can we figure that out if f of x is
log of x
what is f prime of x
f prime of x we don't need to use the
limit definition in fact the limit
definition is quite hard to evaluate
this limit but we know how to take the
derivative of logarithmic functions so f
prime of x is going to be equal to
1 over the natural log of our base our
base here we already talked about that
that is 10
so 1 over natural log of 10
times
times r times x
if this was a natural log well then this
would be 1 over natural log of e times x
natural log of e is just 1. so that's
where you get the 1 over x but if you
have any other base you put the natural
log of that base right over here in the
denominator so what is f prime of 2
f prime of 2 is 1 over the natural log
of 10
times 2.
so this whole thing has simplified
this whole thing is equal to 5
times this business so i could actually
just write it as it's equal to 5
over
5 over the natural log of 10 natural log
of 10
times 2. i could have written it as 2
natural log of 10. the key here for this
type of exercise you might immediately
let me see if i can evaluate this limit
be like well this looks a lot like the
derivative of a logarithmic function
especially the derivative when x is
equal to 2 if we could just factor this
these 5's out so you factor out the 5
you say hey this is this is the
derivative of log of x when x is equal
to 2. and so we know how to take the
derivative derivative of log of x if you
don't know we have videos where we where
we prove
this we take the derivatives of
logarithms with bases other than e
and you just use that to actually and
you find the derivative then you
evaluate it too and then you're done